target number three lieutenant chang has
been flagged by the jtf as a high
priority hostile
chang is a logistics expert that has
been effective in rebuilding the supply
chains for the true sons he needs to be
taken care of before this new influx of
weapons and equipment overwhelms the
last defensive effort that dc has to
offer
[Music]
[Music]
mackenzie chang is a third generation
chinese american who was born and raised
in washington dc
his father and his mother's father were
both in the navy and so like them chang
too wanted to follow in their footsteps
enlisting at 18 he soon discovered that
it wasn't the right fit for him
he hated the water and found the navy
and their rules were not to his liking
he ended up being placed in the ground
transportation team and there he felt
his time and skills were being wasted
eventually things came to a head when he
got himself involved in a bar fight and
as a result he broke his arm and three
ribs
with a year still left on his contract
his family were able to pull some
strings and fortunately for him they
were able to get him an honorable
discharge from the navy
he returned to civilian life and got a
job as a museum security guard within
the local mall
yet he soon realized that being a
security guard at the museum was not as
exciting as he thought it would be and
began to miss regular combat trials
he endeavoured to get some of that
adrenaline rush back
so he tried his hand at airsoft and
hunting yet these two also lacked the
lustre he was after
finally he joined the national guard in
hopes that this would bring some of the
action he was longing for
when the national guard was eventually
called on to secure them all against
peaceful protesters
chang saw this as an opportunity to use
his previous knowledge and expertise as
a mall security guard to set up the
perfect perimeter
general anderson was impressed by the
initiative chang showed and immediately
took him under his wing and logistics
not long after the death of antoine
ridgeway anderson gave chang his own
unit
however he denied him the promotion that
chang so desired in becoming captain
until he could prove himself as a worthy
leader
chang is unwavering in his determination
to demonstrate that he is deserving of
the leadership role and ready for the
title of captain and the admiration of
general anderson
general anderson i just wanted to send
my condolences about dusk and her team
thank you shafer moving forward is there
someone else you'd like me to work with
that won't be necessary
the division has control of your supply
routes in dc how do you think you'll
survive without our assistance well
lieutenant chang has more than enough
experience organizing transpo and supply
drops we no longer require your services
as a glorified errand boy
i think you're making a mistake i've
only made two mistakes in my life the
first was trusting lao the second was
letting her bring you into our operation
good night schaefer
after agent dusk's death schaefer would
get in contact with general anderson
with everything that had gone down they
were no longer willing to work with the
black tusk
rogue agents hunters that seemed unable
to be controlled
and a leadership who were working under
their own hidden agenda
anderson decided that it was no longer
in the true sun's best interest to be
working alongside them
anything they had gained from working
with them was more than being made up
for by the work lieutenant chang was
doing in logistics
baden schaefer would leave a message
with natalya sokolova to update her of
the situation
natalia schaefer just got off the horn
with general anderson he's decided black
tusk supplies and assistance are no
longer required
the true sons are on their own and any
tentative piece we may have brokered has
been severed by the death of lynette
dusk edwards
i'm not comfortable working with the
hunters
this arrangement is creating more
problems and we are losing allies
this is not why i joined the black tusk
schaefer voices his concerns
he explains that agent dusk's death
seemed to be a large part of this
partnership breaking down
but that the hunters are his biggest
problem they can't be trusted
they're jeopardizing the mission
this is not what he signed up for
schaefer would eventually be contacted
by lieutenant chang
shafer this is chang come in good to
hear from you lieutenant you changed
your mind about working together no so
this is a social call dusk was a good
woman and a damn fine soldier
i know she was going to meet you and you
got her killed you know that was beyond
my control you weren't even there
you left her to die
you're right i wasn't there
we've run into some complications what
kind of complications there was another
player on the field what the hell are
you talking about those division agents
weren't the only ones targeting her you
make it sound like she was being stalked
or hunted
chang just wanted to give shafer a piece
of his mind
wanting him to answer for what he did to
dusk
schaefer agreed that he'd let her down
but that there were unexpected
developments
that someone who had been brought in to
help
instead
hunted her down
after feylau's death captain lewis sent
chang into washington dc as part of a
specialized team
his job was to re-establish the true
sun's transportation and supply chain in
the area
however after capturing a number of
important locations in the foggy bottom
district he would quickly appear on the
shd's radar
after battling through chang's countless
number of true sun soldiers
that would eventually catch up to him in
the potomac events center
with the division agent superior
training it wasn't long before
lieutenant chang liked so many before
him
was eliminated
the story behind this manhunt seems to
be less about lieutenant chang and more
about the continuation of the black tusk
and barden schaefer's story including
the falling out with allies the hunters
and shapers potentially wavering
loyalties towards natalya
this whole season seems to be very
heavily focused on the season 3 manhunt
with each of these targets so far
including information around dusk and
the hunter
i have a feeling that this will
eventually lead us to some more
information around the conclusion to
season three where we captured schaefer
we never did find out what he was doing
on coney island
at this stage i'm almost completely
certain that schaefer is going to leave
the black tusk either later on in the
season or potentially in seasons to come
everything we are seeing is pointing us
in that direction
i'm also getting the feeling that there
is more to this general anderson than we
expect
he isn't just another temporary faction
leader that we take out at the end of
the season
i feel like he's going to become
something much larger within the
storyline
but there is one thing i don't quite
understand
where anderson said i've only made two
mistakes in my life the first was
trusting lao the second was letting her
bring you into our operation
what was he talking about here
unless i'm losing the plot i don't
recall any interactions between faye and
anderson up until this point
so maybe this is something we'll hear
about more soon
anyway i think that will do it for this
video i'll get into the next insurance
policy comms in the next one
the only other update i have is that
obviously i recently set up an account
on spotify to upload some of my videos
as podcasts
as i mentioned before i don't really
know what i'm doing in this space and
when mucking around with some of the
settings i seem to have locked one of my
videos behind a subscription
the last thing i want to do is lock any
of my content behind paywalls but before
i realized what i'd done a bunch of
people had paid for a subscription so i
apologize for that i'll be disabling the
subscription option but for those of you
who do want to give a little extra i'll
be reactivating my patreon instead
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay